bruce wayne tons the cape and cow to
protect his beloved gotham city nearly a
century ago since then he has become one
of the most popular superheroes the
world has ever seen but that doesn't
mean there weren't a few hiccups along
the way for example while the caped
crusader is now famous for his no
killing rule older versions of the
character were rather less strict indeed
the early batman terrorized tortured and
killed his enemies proving a stark
contrast to the hero he later became
1940s batman issue 1 features one of
batman's most brutal and shocking kills
one of the issue's stories revolves
around the villainous doctor hugo
strange who uses a serum to transform a
handful of asylum inmates into mindless
destructive giants as they set out to
wreak havoc on the streets of gotham
batman tricks two of the giants into
beating each other to death he then
tracks down a second giant and hangs him
from a noose dangling from his batwing
before using gas pellets to knock
another from the top of a skyscraper
incredibly this isn't even batman's most
brutal kill in those early days of
gotham city as arguably the most
shocking callus of all can be found in
the character's debut story batman first
appeared in 1939's detective comics
issue 27 offering readers their first
glimpse of the man they would come to
know as a dark knight the story opens
with commissioner gordon entertaining
his young friend socialite bruce wayne
in his home during their discussion
gordon reveals that recently he has
become puzzled by a master vigilante
known as the batman soon after gordon is
called to the murder of a chemical
manufacturer named lambert and he offers
to take his friend along for the ride
wayne accepts of course claiming to have
nothing better to do the police
originally suspect the victim's son who
says he pulled the knife from his
father's back when he found him and
witnessed a figure climb out the window
the younger lambert says his father's
last word was contract and tells the
police that his father had just entered
into a contract with three men alfred
striker paul rogers and stephen crane
while gordon goes to see crane bruce
wayne returns home to put on his bat
suit because he's the batman bet you
didn't see that coming holy masquerade
unfortunately crane is already dead
although batman arrives at the scene
just in time to find his killers he
knocks one out and then throws the other
off the top of a two-story building and
while callously dropping someone from 30
feet up is bad enough that's only the
second worst thing batman does to
someone in his debut story after tossing
his foe off the roof batman discovers
that paul rogers and alfred striker are
due to meet in stryker's laboratory
their striker attempts to kill rogers
but batman intervenes pausing for just
long enough to explain strikers
dastardly plan to take control of the
apex chemical corporation then when
stryker pulls a gun to shoot them both
batman punches him so hard that he
breaks through a metal railing falling
into a vat of acid when a surprise
rogers points out what's happening
batman callously comments that it is a
fitting end for his kind later when
gordon tells the story to his wealthy
friend bruce wayne wayne says it all
sounds like a lovely fairy tale after
that the dark knight would kill again
multiple times using fire physical
beatings and even guns to dispatch his
foes
in fact the first few batman stories in
the world of detective comics read more
like a full-blown rampage than a career
in vigilantism as time went by however
dc comics decided to pull batman away
from his pulp fiction roots and make him
more of a genuine superhero and that
meant no killing by batman issue 4 he
was telling robin never to kill with
weapons of any kind and before long the
no kill rule had become one of the core
tenets of bruce wayne's crime-fighting
philosophy
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you